Let's take a quick look at three things you should do...
...to successfully manage your online course...
...and stay motivated throughout the semester.
First, you should carefully read the course syllabus.
It's full of great information.
Many students unfortunately forget to read it...
...and then wonder why they don't understand their assignments,...
...course expectations, important due dates and grading criteria.
At the beginning of each week, you should make it a habit...
...to review the assignments that are due that week...
...and any other activities that need to be completed...
...and set reminders for yourself.
Second, successful students use a calendar to plan...
...and manage their weekly study times.
Remembering to study, participating in online discussions...
...and completing assignments for your online course...
...can be challenging when you're juggling all the distractions of life.
So, make a plan, get organized...
...and schedule all the time you will need to complete your online course requirements...
...and then stick to your plan.
And third, don't be a stranger to your online course.
Log into your course regularly, even daily, if possible.
This is another strategy successful online learners use.
Logging in frequently is associated with higher grades.
Consistent frequent access to your course allows you to respond...
...to important course announcements.
Review course expectations and interact with classmates in discussion boards.
If you do this consistently,...
...you'll build valuable connections with other students in the course...
...and opportunities for cooperation and collaboration.
And this will enrich your online learning experience.